you know what's interesting and and it
may raise more questions and it sounds
so philosophical but I do believe that
when you come to a point in your life
and I believe that you would only
realize that when you're at that point
wherein you could take us take step back
and look at the bigger picture of course
I'm not that old yet and I feel like I
still have a lot of ways to go in a lot
more experiences and love them of people
to meet and learn from so I'm not
professing them I know everything I'm
perfect but yet I do tend to believe
that when you come to that point and you
look at the entire picture it all ties
back to one thing it's all it's all and
it's amazing when you come to think of
it as if each and every one of us has
has a role to play has a story to tell
and when you look at your own story in
comes to a full circle and and and for
me like like for me when when I was in
high school I was doing something and
everybody believes that Albion
entertainment unfortunately or whatever
you take come of it being Asian in the
Philippines and being the eldest I was
supposed to be you know I have the
business don't do that do this and at
that time entertainment is not really a
money maker without being too Tony just
business or science and I believe that
this it holds true for a lot of cultures
to like if you see and I've heard of
this a lot you've seen Indian comedians
or Chinese comedians always say oh my
parents complained about me wanting to
be a comedian because they all wanted me
to be a lawyer a doctor or scientist or
all that I want to be a comedian and yet
it's the comedy or the art that made
them richer and famous and not that
there's nothing wrong being rich and
famous but I mean what if they become
doctors would they get to that point
maybe they'll be yeah a good doctor but
will they reach that point we're in
they'll be traveling around the world
touring and all that stuff maybe not you
know even i am night shyamalan if i'm
not mistaken uh he was pushed to be a
physician and he doesn't want to
but then he wrote with everybody's
favorite and sure enough first paycheck
I believe he bought his dad I
mercedes-benz if i'm not mistaken and on
the night that he opened the door to the
car he told his dad hey do you think
this would happen if I followed your
advice or something to that I don't know
exactly the same exact but it's
something like that and going back to
like everything falls back in the in a
circle is that so when I was younger
everybody feels like I would be in
entertainment and that just didn't
happen and then I had a family tragedy
and now I'm a doctor so I did finish and
got licensed for medicine in the
Philippines but yep I just kept shake
off the bug if it is really true it's
funny because there's no artist in my
family there's no rider there's a
filmmaker there's no nobody else
everybody's in business and and it's
funny too because I and the first doctor
in the family so I'm the first artist
and I'm the first doctor the doctor
because of something that happened and
the artist because I feel like you know
that's my passion that's where i'm i'm
in and that's my contribution to the
world it's funny because even when i was
doing my internships in the emergency
room and we were waiting for patients i
would
right on my yellow pad before the iPad
laptops aren't in yet back in the
eighties so I would write my scripts in
yellow pad legal pad and then I get home
and then I I manually type it and then
read it and then like it or not then I
realize it but all manually type writing
it and then I submitted it to a friend
of mine who's an editor and he liked it
he submitted it to the director of that
TV show and he liked it and it was
support it was it was not supposed to be
aired or even shop because that TV show
was geared for young love sweet love
it's about you know teenyboppers needing
the pure prince charming being swept off
your feet and happily ever after while
my story was about teenage love but then
they were young daughters and they got
married but for the wrong reasons now
they have a kid and the young doctor had
an affair with the nurse and it just
didn't end up happily ever after so it
was not really within the confines of
that series so the creative board said
no we can't have that kind of story but
my heart goes out to the director and
he's still around in the Philippines he
said no I love this let's do it
so and I'm director I could do whatever
I want so hats off to him he pushed it
and they did it and it had that episode
rated number two for the entire life
season of that show so proves that it's
not all Wow Prince Charming's and all
the end there's no reality here there is
an audience for something real I guess
and that actually opened opened my way
into the Philippine film in this TV and
film industry and then late later on I
won award nah not on the ward with a
contest or writing contest that enabled
me to meet more people and then just
it's just networking so it's the same
here say anything but it's all about
proving your worth just right if you're
a writer just film something if you're a
filmmaker and and let it go and see
where it takes you and so I am a doctor
and that enabled me to come here but
then it all goes back this it's like a
full circle all the way because here I
am now talking about film I'm not
talking about health care I'm not
talking about the pros and cons of
Obamacare you know I
you know we're not talking about cancer
research which I do we're talking about
film so so yeah in a sense still a lot
to learn but I do believe in my personal
life it just came full circle so
you